one of your many fascinating
um surveys is on fetishes
you wrote a blog post about it
uh probably several because it's like a
huge difference still in progress yeah
so uh the one I'm referring to is on
popularity and tabooness
of various fetishes so what are some
interesting takeaways I gotta pull up
this graph because it's freaking epic
yes this is a big graph and it has
taboo-ness as one axis and
um popularity as the other okay for
people just listening on the x-axis is
taboo-ness yeah
asked to rate how taboo Society viewed
the sexual interest and on the y-axis is
percent of people reporting interest log
scale
oh boy all right so just some examples
on the low tabooness and high popularity
there's a there's a correlation here I
think you said it's 0.69 yeah it's just
not it's just hilarious is it still 0.69
are you tracking that I I haven't that
was the most since I did this yeah uh so
like the last taboo stuff is more likely
to be popular and the more taboo stuff
is less likely to be popular and on the
like missionary position
fingering vagina [__]
light spanking cuddling cuddling is more
taboo than missionary
I think people are conceiving like if
you're like I'm really sexually aroused
by cuddling specifically sure then like
that's a little more weird than getting
specifically harassed by [__] you
expect people to be aroused by blow jobs
so this was like getting at like as a
fetish versus like an activity yes as
specific as like a concrete sexual
interest like I'm specifically
interested in this thing yeah and so
those are thighs and lips different body
parts jaw lines and then some of it is
color based on more female preference
versus uh male preference like Jaw lines
is more
uh female preference
being submissive is more a female
preference slight bondage
yeah more female there's a lot of
interesting ones there's so much okay
but then on the The Far Side of that I
mean it gets pretty dark
but even all along the way like extreme
bondage being at 50 tabunus
pegging pain giving pain sexual
frustration I I suppose like as a kink
uh yeah
and there's so many interesting ones
like to me like just that I haven't even
like considered
yeah I had to do so much research in the
fetishes to to compile the list because
I'm surprising like options to you that
you're like oh okay this is like a
fetish yeah well more confusing was like
what the fetishes are about because like
I didn't want to overlap fetish it so I
had to kind of look into them yeah and
I'm like there's like such interesting
manifestations of core drives like
you're really harassed by disgust like
maybe you're very into rolling around in
dirt but you're not into rolling around
with ice cream so I'm like okay I have
to make those into two separate fetishes
you know yeah and like I'm seeing like a
at the far end
uh
rodents
um
like different types of incest
branding so it's like pain and then
spoon [__] sex with animals I guess
dogs horses
receiving oral sex from an animal is
high tabunas and pretty high popularity
surprisingly High popularity I was
really shocked by that one I wouldn't
triple check that number because I'm
like no way this amount of people are
reporting interest do you know which
animal is there no I didn't specify I
asked like which animals are robotic and
then I separately asked like how erotic
is it to receive oral sex from your
preferred animal
this is so fascinating so I I would uh
like can we just talk about the
methodology of this hey
this feels like deeply honest
map of humanity in a way we don't
usually map Humanity yeah
like because it's so me like your
fetishes are so meaningful to each each
individual person yeah that's what I
love about this work it's like nobody
cares about your someone's fetishes you
never get to express them and if you
have a more unusual fetish people
usually judge you so it's like this tiny
little pocket of like this shame thing
but it's so cool to me that like human
braids could be oriented in such a way
like like wound [__] like like
somebody finds that so erotic and that's
so cool
yeah and then they probably and it
should be explored like how did that
come to be you mentioned that we like to
construct narratives that somehow was
grounded in childhood but maybe it's
genetic maybe it has to do with maybe
you can actually form and unform that
fetish very quickly I don't know uh this
is one of the things that I'm
researching so in the big survey that
I'm doing I asked so many questions
about childhood all the ones that I
think like we have common theories that
about like oh are you abused it is you
yelled it by a man or a woman
um stuff like that like are you was
really sexually repressive you know was
it gender roles were you expected to
conform a whole bunch of stuff and then
I asked you know obviously about like a
massive amount of fetishes and my sample
size right now is 500 000 people 500
yeah it's massive and I have stated for
all of it and the result looks like uh
that's not really correlated nothing
that I asked about in childhood nothing
correlates with fetish preference later
in life it does correlate with onset
lots of things that happen in childhood
can TR like change like the the age at
which it triggers they have so me
fascinating blog post he had a blog post
I think on the age of fetish onset yeah
and uh like you uh you really nicely
organized it by age
like reproduction as a fetish I guess
pregnancy yeah as at age of 17 about
16.9
uh toys and like anal beads is 15.5
yeah one of the interesting things I
found I mean this data set's so huge
it's taking me a long time to go through
it so this is like Snippets from what I
remember when I was glancing through the
data so this part is not rigorous but I
seem to get the impression that um if
you are if a fetish occurs for you
earlier like even much earlier onset
you're more likely to report being
extremely interested into it so later
onset means you're going to be like less
into the fetish but if it hits earlier
but I wonder if it passes like
it's really yeah I didn't measure old
fetishes at all like no longer right you
used to but it is no longer there
interesting one interesting thing that I
don't understand is that um that uh
non-cis people seem to have more
correlation between childhood
experiences and fetishes so I was saying
that there's no correlation between
childhood experience divisions this
holds for CIS people the trans people
especially trans men there's a
correlation it doesn't mean they have
absolutely higher rates of abuse or
fetishes or anything but I'm just saying
that like for them there does actually
seem to be some sort of connection
between childhood experiences and
sexuality later in life and I don't
understand why this applies to one group
but not the other I don't have a good
theory for that so usually you try like
when you see something like that you'll
try to construct Theory and see if you
can find like
you keep that theory in mind like a
hypothesis of why it would be and then
you ask further questions to try to
elaborate
so can you maybe talk about the
methodology of how you got the 500 000
like what
uh like how did this come to be yeah
this is I might go into way too much
detail about this because I thought
about this so much because I'm like the
question is how do you get a lot of
people to take a big survey the longer
survey is the lower the response rate
um and I really wanted to do one big
comprehensive survey so I could like
check a whole bunch of correlations with
it within it uh because it's you know
more annoying and it's harder to get a
lot of people to retake similar surveys
to each other at a time so I'm like okay
I need to convince a very large number
of people to take a lot of these
questions and even building the
questions that was really hard because
I'm like okay I need a comprehensive
amount of fetishes I can't ask everybody
to answer for every single Niche fetish
I'm like do you like ball gags do you
like funnel gags do you like wife shrew
gags or whatever I'm like you can't do
that nobody's gonna do this okay
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna ask
questions what's the wife true but okay
I I'm not doing the I'm trying to refer
to like there's like a thing
types of gags okay
um yeah different so I'm like so what I
need to do is I need to ask people a
question like are you in like bondage
and if you say yes then then I'll go ask
you all the bondage questions ah got it
right but then this seems simple but
then it just exploded because I'm like
how do I categorize these fetishes it's
like if you're into sploshing uh which
is what's that like uh you like sitting
in cakes you like getting in mud but
basically like kind of messy sensory
like is this a disgusting is it a
humiliation thing is it a sensory thing
like which category anyway so it took me
like two months of just agonizing over
each fetish because you don't want to
miss a fetish you don't want to like
have a really important thing that you
accidentally put in a discuss category
when it actually belongs in the
humiliation category you know well let
me think about that because like you're
still catching it you're just
miscategory categorizing it right
because if you're into splashing and
you're like this is clearly humiliation
sick so you say yes I'm into humiliation
stuff and then I don't ask you about
splashing then I'm missing a whole data
set of people
because of falsely categorized a
question you're going to miss stuff
you're just picking what to what's less
and less important to miss well I'm
trying to get people into the right
question set sure because like I can't
ask you all the questions I have to ask
you a couple overarching questions to
know what specific questions to ask you
and so I have to those overarching
questions have to be really really well
calibrated so that I can accurately feed
you into the right sub part of the
survey awesome so that was extremely
difficult if I'm when I'm dealing with I
think it was like 850 fetishes
um so I did a couple things to spot
check I like I did a couple questions
where I asked um like in the detailed in
the survey but like also the beginning
of the survey just to see like what cap
percentage people I was capturing
um but and then and then I scored the
survey so if you take it I had other
people answer preliminary surveys where
they gave me data about how taboo the
various fetishes were and then I used
that data so that when you fill out the
survey
um it's extremely comprehensive and you
get data about exactly how taboo your
interests are and you get a score at the
end and I can give you an equivalent
kinky character which I also had people
write a whole bunch of fictional
characters and some historic ones about
like how kinky they were so then I
matched the historic character Kiki
character to your score so that makes it
like more fun like gamifies it a little
bit and you could well you can brag
about Minecraft to be able to share it
with others sure and a lot of the
characters really goofy like like either
SpongeBob and like Hitler's on there and
you know South Park characters what is
what is uh what Kink does Hitler have I
think he's like he's around Marilyn
Monroe
which is like a slightly above average
oh sorry
I thought there was like a
two-dimensional space somehow so this is
like a literally from zero just how
kinky yeah so here's the bottom who's uh
the most what's the character from Willy
Wonka is the most kinky yeah
okay I think like maybe Captain America
was the least kinky or something or
Gandhi
meanwhile but that's another
conversation
good boy
uh yeah so even viral and Tick Tock
basically because people were like what
I got this insane character and then Mr
the sample size exploded from 4 40 000
to 500 000.
wow so like all it took is that kind of
incentive what did you like uh at first
have to pay people for the server
and uh what what about the demographic
of the different people that took it I'm
mostly younger so usually early 20s
um predominantly female like 70 female
pretty like I wraps a lot of tick tock
demographics pretty well yeah oh okay I
got it but that's interesting was young
people are probably better for this kind
of survey because this is probably a
culture that's a little bit more honest
about their sexuality uh yeah most
likely I think people are incentivized
to be honest when they're getting a true
identity response out of it
like sure if you're you're doing it for
money you don't care but like if you are
invested in the result you want to know
what the the truth of the answers are
then you actually
it's possible that you also don't want
to know the truth this is true but on
average hopefully that doesn't I mean
there's these are really difficult like
what what is there some interesting
little quirks that
um people should know about about your
methodology that you had to kind of
solve to try to get to a really good
survey so one of you said is the
categorization to make it more efficient
is there some for the analysis part yeah
so the the graph that you're talking
about it's um it's a binary so it's like
if you and if somebody expressed even a
little bit of Interest then it goes into
the graph so it's like 80 of people
expressed even a little bit of Interest
so it's not representing degree of
interest it's not differentiating
between them at all so it's possible
that like some fetishes have exactly the
same amount of people like are at least
a little bit into them but one of them
is very extreme interest and the other
is like
fake and not very intense so that's not
reflected I also like probably didn't
represent the visual part right like
might not be intuitive but he chose a
log scale but it was kind of spreads
things out to makes it more and more
clear because the linear it was just so
clustered at the bottom you couldn't
really separate it out so there's
obviously a selection effects that's
possible that like the identity results
at the end impacted people's results a
little bit but the thing is like I'm
comparing it to what exists like what is
the alternative and right now the
research on this stuff is terrible so
it's like I'm not saying my research is
perfect um but it's like at least it's
something like it's something that's
pointing us maybe in a direction that we
might be able to do more research on and
you're making the data available yeah
yeah I'm doing it slowly because uh it
they're so I ask about so many questions
it's like not very anonymized so I'm
really seeing small sections of the data
at a time yeah
have you uh have you published in like
journals and stuff no I haven't yeah any
interest in that or is your your
approach I'm like I'm conflicted about
it like it sounds cool because then I
could really call her on publish from
the journal and then people who are
yelling about me who don't know anything
about statistics on Twitter like that I
can go like shove it in their face but
then you're also giving in to the silly
criticism like I don't like I want I
feel so passionate about extra science
like science that you can just like I
want to make science accessible like
anybody can just go look and learn about
the basics of like doing a survey or
figuring out how to interpret
information
um and June doing a published Journal
feels like I'm I'm betraying my cause a
little bit that's often behind the
paywall yeah it's uh it goes against the
I mean I think you not publishing a
journal is doing a big public service
thank you oh it's just coming from like
on this topic the elite the elitism I
see on the psychology side with the
journals and the Academia the positions
and the institutions you come from all
that that goes against
um I think that's more useful for math
and computer science and so on where
there's like
clear like but even then even then code
is code data is data yeah like uh
Prestige shouldn't matter at all
um maybe maybe for like
like biological experiments like
fireology or something like that
it's good to be from a major lab that
has a reputation for like going through
all the procedures like you know you can
trust but here like you're dealing with
a giant mess of humanity like it it's
beautiful to be transparent to be raw to
be exploring it together with everybody
yeah it's really beautiful I have people
like have a lot of incentive to doubt
the results like a lot of the research
I'm doing is to like assists and trans
people like like we don't have any data
about transsexuality like not very good
at least
um and I'm really curious I don't really
have an agenda about it I think like
being trans is cool if you want to be
trans do it and like I have some
skepticism about like gender Theory but
like it doesn't come down to impact like
the way I think trans people should be
treated which I think is like treat them
you know be [__] nice and human about
it I don't know but when I'm talking
about the the thing like my conclusions
are that like uh transsexuality is
really unique
um it's not like like sister or CIS
woman or man sexuality at all and me
this is super cool but like a lot of
people this is very politicized right
now like the data into like transsexual
preferences like it's so loaded which is
really sad because I am very accepting
of weird sexuality like if you're into a
weird thing I'm like good for you this
is super cool like let's figure out how
to make it so that you can explore the
thing you're into without any stigma but
because there's so much stigma that like
if you find that one demographic is in
the weirder sex stuff than the other
like it's hard to present that in a way
that people don't weaponize so it's been
it's been really politically touchy
subject here yeah but you do it in a way
that's not this it's not feel like it
has an agenda right you're just
exploring yeah I feel pretty open to
what I'm gonna find like I often have no
idea what the date is going to tell me
and I'm like I pre-commit like okay I
could say a b or c and I'm like down to
publish any of those findings